we're gonna take a turn now to a
cultural Powerhouse you may never have
heard of but more for more than 50 years
a half century ballet hispanico in New
York City has been training top tier
dancers including big names like
Jennifer Lopez with a school that takes
kids as young as two it is America's
largest latinx Cultural Arts
organization and was recently named one
of the nation's cultural Treasures by
the Ford Foundation Adriana Diaz got an
inside look and met some of the
company's most talented dancers
[Applause]
welcome Bienvenidos to ballet hispanico
one two three four this is a school
and safe haven for dancers who are
mostly latinx
who like other dancers of color have
historically been marginalized in the
mostly white world of classical dance
foreign
as a child I really wanted to be in like
New York City Ballet or American Ballet
Theater like and I had a teacher tell me
like oh you know like you being black
and a Latina you know like your body
you're gonna end up being too like
voluptuous to to be in those companies
Gabrielle's Brave Bloom who's Guatemalan
and black overcame resistance and racial
stereotyping growing up dancing in
Georgia I built resilience a lot of
resilience and a lot of strength that
kids of color start building from way
too young why should it be so hard for
you to Just Dance
hahaha but at ballet hispanico she feels
at home in the professional company
which Embraces the vibrancy and
diversity of latinx culture in both its
choreography and casting Paolo Hernandez
farrella calls this a safe space here
we're free to be our true selves I'm
free to be Hispanic I am free to be
queer I am free to be who I am and the
purest form and I really feel safe
artistic director Eduardo valaro also
found belonging dancing for the company
for kids like me who came from the Bronx
and felt like they were othered this
place gives them a home base and that's
why it's so miraculous to have this
organization today it's a miracle it is
because the organization started thanks
to one woman in 1970 Tina Ramirez a
Venezuelan immigrant knew the
transformative power of dance a
collective creates Community posture
creates Pride how do you feel you have
to stand nice and tall
[Music]
does it make you feel strong yeah
you're strong right show me you're
strong
sixteen-year-old Renata Suarez dances
here five days a week
arriving home after 9 pm she does It For
the Love of Dance and a love of herself
that's grown here when I was younger I
struggled a little bit to still connect
with my identity because you know I
think immigrant children have a hard
time
finding finding a place here in the U.S
that changed when she saw ballet
hispanico perform I think it was
it was bad I had ever been in my life
I'd never seen people like be that up
front and be that like this is who we
are and this is how we dance and this is
what we do to know that there is a child
somewhere just like me that will shift
that will stand taller that will find
themselves that will find belonging to
move forward in life that's everything
in the past a sense of belonging eluded
the organization itself in the face of
stereotyping and pigeonholing I was so
proud of the fact that I was about a
hispanical dancer and I was saying why
don't people gnome why don't people know
about ballet Hispanic we were often not
supported as much as the big companies
we were often oh it's the Latino company
that's nice but that's not really
serious now they are on the map
their block was recently named ballet
hispanico way and they regularly share
the stage with the likes of American
Ballet Theater and Alvin Ali some kids
will be like oh my God I saw the
Flamenco things that you were doing but
you were also kind of doing ballet and
then you also look like me seeing us
perform truly is magical even if you
watch from the wings
you know getting down and really
enjoying it can you give me your best
Grita oh my gosh
[Applause]
she hears me saying that right yelling
loud and proud for their roots
for CBS mornings Adriana Diaz New York
and just so our viewers know ballet
hispanico's 2023 season begins on June
1st at City Center here in New York
that's why it's so important Adriana
thank you for that story that you can
see yourself and see the representation
I love when he says people thought oh
nice but not so serious not only the
nice series but how about excellent
that's right how about excellent
outstanding I love looking at a dancer's
body loud and proud yes
that's right bravo bravo